[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Якісний виноград дасть хороше вино.
Я вино не роблю, я вирощую виноград.
Вино робить творець.
[Великі Береги,
Закарпаття]
Ось тут у нас 5 рядів Б'янки.
Рислінг Рейнський, Шираз,
[Іван Урста
Власник виноробні «Sümegi Pince»]
Мускат Оттонель, Іршаї Олівер,
Сапераві Північний...
Тут унизу ця площина така.
Там навіть проглядається листя,
таке зеленіше листя там скраю —
Каберне Совіньйон.
Отут виноград можна бачити
цей — Блау Франкіш.
Сік тут білий, хоча виноград синій.
Це зараз не найбільші грона, але цукристість...
Зараз подивимось,
яка в нього цукристість.
Двадцять чотири з половиною.
[Берегове,
Закарпаття]
Має значення: на який схил, на яку площу,
який виноград можна висадити.
«Кущ» з угорської мови...
«Кущ» і «капітал» — одне й те саме.
Я народився в угорській сім'ї.
Батьки мої робили вина.
Для мене то була така напруга.
[Василь Надь
Власник виноробні  «Nota Bene»]
Не можна сказати, що я дуже любив
у виноградниках сюсюкатись.
Це було для мене як покарання.
Уже десь після сорока років свого життя
я щодалі, то більше полюбляю цю справу.
Фактично на сьогодні в нас є
шістнадцять найменувань готових вин.
Є шість білих, чотири — червоних сухих.
Це Каберне-Совіньйон, Мерло,
Аліберне, Ізабелла.
Напівсолодкі вина і «десерти»
певною мірою вже містять рецептуру
і купажі суміші цих сортів.
Тут з різних років відкладені ті вина,
які певного року поводились унікально.
Тобто краще інших
і тому заслужили на честь,
що ми його відклали на подальше зберігання.
Цій купці сімнадцять років.
[Берегове,
Закарпаття]
Закарпатські вина,
я б сказав, відрізняються
[Геннадій Гутман
Власник виноробні «Chateаu Chizay»]
від вин інших регіонів нашої країни.
Це і завдяки нашим виноградарям і виноробам,
і, звичайно, регіону —
в нас унікальний регіон.
Це дає робити дуже високоякісні вина,
які анітрохи не поступаються європейським.
Тут не було нічого взагалі, лише поле.
І 1999-го року ми
збудували це підприємство.
Нашим найстарішим
виноградникам дванадцять років.
Я народився та виріс у Мукачево,
а в Закарпатті, мабуть, всі були виноробами.
Мій дідусь приділяв особливу увагу
виноградарству і виноробству.
І, мабуть, прищепив мені цю любов.
Тут чотири епохи виноградарства
нашого краю.
Почнемо з України,
до цього був Радянський Союз,
раніше були Чехословаччина та Угорщина.
Ще раніше: Трансильванія,
Австрійська імперія та Австро-Угорщина.
[Бене,
Закарпаття]
Після сухого закону Горбачова
треба було відновлювати виноробство.
Батько і дід створили нам плантацію,
тому ми з братом вже отримали її,
нам залишилося тільки
придумати технологію.
[Гергей Параска
Співвласник виноробні «Parászka Pincészet»]
Перші два роки були дуже складні.
Треба було знайти наші вина,
наше виготовлення, нашу технологію,
те, що ми хочемо, як хочемо і так далі.
Один сорт винограду,
десять господарів — десять різних вин.
Починаємо крутити.
Дуже люблю.
Цього дуже багато не п'ємо,
бо це свіжий сік,
там ще грибки, бактерії і так далі.
Шкірки виноградів ще бродитимуть.
Можливо, щось легке вже виходить,
аби не було проблем з тим.
Але дегустуємо завжди сам сік,
яка терпкість, яка солодкість і так далі.
Який мав вигляд сік і яке вино
потім хочеш отримувати, для порівняння.
Здебільшого ми п'ємо, бо дуже любимо.
[Берегове,
Закарпаття]
Починаємо перше вино дегустувати.
Перше вино це — Черсегі,
місцеве регіональне вино.
Чому місцеве регіональне?
Бо виробляється з сорту винограду,
який трапляється
тільки на Закарпатті та в Угорщині.
Називається Черсеги Фюсереш.
З угорської мови перекладається
як «черсигський пряний».
Тобто в ароматі цього вина ви
можете відчути квітково-пряні нотки.
Звертайте увагу на прозорість вина,
не пийте вин мутних.
І ви можете трохи розкрутити вино
в келиху. Для чого?
Щоб розбудити аромат, щоб
краще відчути ароматику.
Відчуєте квітково-пряний аромат
з легкими фруктовими нотками.
Солодкувате вино, хоч вино сухе.
Зробіть хороший ковток, від кінчика язика проведіть поверхнею язика.
Потримайте 2-3 секунди,
щоб відчути смак,
щоб усі рецептори, які ми маємо на
язику, на його кінчику, з боків, на піднебінні,
щоб рецептори передали смак вина
в наш головний мозок,
щоб ми усвідомили смак.
І після того ковтаємо.
Ціль нашої сім'ї — зберегти те,
що було на Закарпатті спокон віків.
Наші вина — живі вина.
Живе вино народжується
на винограднику,
передробило, воно бродить там.
Це грубе бродіння, відбувається грубе бродіння,
після цього ми закачуємо вина в ці бочки.
Тут відбувається тихе бродіння, яке продовжується
залежно від температури,
внутрішньої, зовнішньої, від багатьох складових.
Два, три, п'ять, шість місяців...
Значить, воно, по-перше, нефільтроване,
непастеризоване і неконсервоване.
Це ознаки живого вина.
Фактично всі вина, що ми реалізуємо,
ми витримуємо у...
Я сам виготовляю дубові діжки.
Ми витримуємо вина від двох,
до трьох, до п'яти років,
відповідно до рецептури,
якої вино потребує.
Узимку, влітку тут 12°C.
Живе культура благородної винної плісняви.
Вид грибка, який абсолютно нейтральний до вин,
не дає йому ніяких побічних ефектів.
А вбиває все інше.
Схожих підвалів на нашій вулиці,
десь на відстані 1 км, є близько сорока.
Вони залишилися із часів Угорщини.
Було характерно для кожного районного
чи обласного центру в ті часи
концентрувати виноробів на одній вулиці.
Тобто це колись так вулиця називалася,
вулиця Шампань.
І кожен зі заможних виноградарів, виноробів
старався тримати свій підвал на цій вулиці.
Прізвище мого діда Шимегі.
Мій дід прищепив мені любов
до землі і до цієї культури.
Рік народження діда...
2007 рік — коли ми цей бренд зробили.
Звідти взяв в оренду землю
і почав садити виноград.
Усе вручну, все з допомогою
Господа Бога і своєї пенсії.
Років через сто,
як ми з вами зустрінемось,
тут буде перше українське шато.
Шато Sümegi Pince.
У нас велика конкуренція,
але якщо є проблема,
то допомагаємо одне одному.
Ми знаємо: ми конкуренти у виноробстві —
це одна річ,
але ми однаковао — люди...
Всі любимо вина, любимо
свою професію і допомагаємо.
Просто без любові і відданості
цій культурі багато не зробиш.
Я знаю це.
Виноград любить сонце і тінь.
Ну це нонсенс: сонце і тінь,
у тіні виноград не росте.
Але й без тіні господаря теж не росте.
Якщо не кожен день, то через день,
щоб кущик бачив тінь господаря,
що він там пройшов, подивився,
познайомився з ним:
все гаразд — і пішов далі.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко
Олег Марчук
Макс Завалля]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Наталка Вишинська
Олександра Панченко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]